♪♪
Tyra: PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
IT ALL STARTED
IN NEW YORK CITY
WHERE 12 WOMEN
OF VARIOUS SHAPES, SIZES
AND BACKGROUNDS ARRIVED
FROM ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
Xiomara: HEY,
WHAT'S YOUR NAME?
Catie: CATIE.
WHAT'S YOURS?
Xiomara:
XIOMARA.
♪♪♪
Tyra: WHILE FRIENDSHIPS
FORMED BETWEEN SOME...
Xiomara: COME HERE.
Tyra: CONFLICT BREWED
BETWEEN OTHERS.
Camille: AND TRUST ME, IF I
HAVE SOMETHING TO SAY TO YOU...
Yoanna: I DON'T TRUST YOU.
Camille: I WILL SAY IT
TO YOUR FACE.
Yoanna:
I DO NOT TRUST YOU.
Sara: WHOO!
Camille: JUST STAY
AWAY FROM ME.
Tyra: THE GIRLS
HAD TO PROVE
THEY COULD WORK
ON DIFFICULT SHOOTS...
Nolé: SHE LOOKED LIKE
A WALRUS WEARING CHIFFON.
Tyra: ACT...
Camille: WHY DID YOU HAVE
TO LEAVE ME?
Tyra: TAKE CRITICISM...
Simon: GO DOWN WHERE THE HOOKERS
HANG OUT BY THE DOCKS
AND SEE WHAT
THEY'RE WEARING
AND THEN AVOID IT.
Tyra: AND DANCE
IN MY VERY OWN MUSIC VIDEO.
Man: CUT.
Tyra:
♪ PACK YOUR BAGS, Y'ALL ♪
♪ YOU'RE GOING
TO MILAN! ♪♪
Women:
(screaming)
Tyra: THE GIRLS THEN GOT
TO SHOW THEIR STUFF
IN MILAN,
ITALY,
WHERE
THE COMPETITION INTENSIFIED.
Camille: THIS IS
MY SIGNATURE WALK,
AND THIS IS WHAT'S GOING
TO MAKE ME FAMOUS.
Eric:
(groaning)
Janice: CAMILLE,
WHAT WERE YOU THINKING?
Tyra: AND SHANDI LOST FOCUS
WHEN SHE HAD A CARELESS FLING.
Eric:
You had sex?!
Shandi: YEAH.
Eric: (crying)
Oh, my God, honey.
Tyra: THE COMPETITION
HAS BEEN FIERCE,
BUT NINE VERY DIFFICULT CUTS
HAD TO BE MADE.
Xiomara:
(sniffles)
Catie:
Sara:
(sobbing)
Camille:
CIAO.
April:
(crying)
Tyra: TONIGHT IT'S DOWN
TO THREE FINALISTS.
FROM DAY ONE,
MERCEDES CHARMED THE JUDGES
WITH HER WARM
AND BUBBLY PERSONALITY.
Janice:
BAD PROM, BABY.
Mercedes:
I LOOKED GOOD AT MY PROM.
(laughter)
Tyra: HER ENTHUSIASM
AND CHARM ONLY HID THE PAIN
OF HER SECRET STRUGGLE
WITH LUPUS--
A CHRONIC AND
PAINFUL ILLNESS.
Mercedes:
I'M SCARED.
Tyra: MERCEDES NEVER
GAVE IN,
AND SHE FOUND A WAY
TO SHINE ON EVERY SHOOT
AND IN EVERY CHALLENGE,
BUT IN
THE FASHION INDUSTRY,
THERE IS SUCH A THING
AS BEING TOO CUTE.
James: OH, NO,
TOO CUTE.
Mercedes:
I'M TOO CUTE.
Tyra: TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
MERCEDES HAS TO SHOW
THE JUDGES HER EDGINESS.
♪♪
NOW YOANNA GREW UP
WITH A PASSION FOR FASHION.
SHE KNEW
THAT ONE DAY
SHE WANTED TO BE
A HIGH FASHION MODEL,
BUT YOANNA ALSO KNEW THAT SHE
HAD TO SHED NEARLY 50 POUNDS.
AFTER WORKING WITH A TRAINER
AND EATING HEALTHY,
YOANNA GOT INTO PEAK
MODELING CONDITION.
HER SELF-CONFIDENCE
WAVERED FROM TIME TO TIME,
BUT HER GORGEOUS LOOKS
WOWED THE JUDGES.
Janice: YOU HAVE A CLASSIC FACE
MADE FOR BEAUTY.
Tyra: DESPITE
HER BEAUTIFUL FACE,
SHE WAS OFTEN
INCONSISTENT.
J.: YOUR WALK REALLY
IS AS USELESS
AS A FLASHLIGHT
WITH NO BATTERIES IN THE DARK.
Tyra: TONIGHT YOANNA'S
GOTTA DELIVER A PERFORMANCE
THAT IS FLAWLESS.
NOW TOP MODELS
CAN BE BORN,
OR THEY CAN
BE MADE.
Shandi: HI.
Tyra: SHANDI WAS A CLERK
AT A MISSOURI WALGREENS.
HER LIFE COULDN'T HAVE BEEN
ANY MORE DIFFERENT
THAN THE LIFE
OF A MODEL,
AND SHE KNEW SHE HAD
A LOT OF WORK AHEAD OF HER.
SO SHE LOST
THE GLASSES,
WENT BLONDE...
Shandi:
I FEEL SO PRETTY.
Tyra: AND HER WALK
FINALLY IMPROVED.
♪♪
WE'VE GIVEN HER THE TOOLS
SHE NEEDS TO BE A TOP MODEL,
BUT WITH HER RECENT
PERSONAL CRISIS,
WILL SHE BE ABLE TO
PULL HERSELF TOGETHER
AND FOCUS TO TAKE IT
ALL THE WAY?
WE'LL SEE.
Mercedes:
(grunting)
Tyra:
IT ALL BEGINS NOW
ON THE SEASON FINALE OF
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
♪♪♪
Yoanna: AW, LOOK.
"KICK ASS FOR ME.
I AM HERE IN SPIRIT."
I WASN'T EXPECTING APRIL
TO BE ELIMINATED.
YOU KNOW,
I THOUGHT APRIL
WOULD HAVE BEEN ONE
OF THE TOP THREE.
IT'S JUST LIKE,
ANY GIVEN TIME,
SOMEONE
COULD LEAVE.
(telephone rings)
Mercedes' mom:
Hello?
Mercedes:
MOMMY.
Mercedes' mom:
Hi-- how are you?
Mercedes:
EVERYTHING'S GOOD.
I'M FEELING GOOD.
Mercedes' mom:
Good.
Mercedes: WHAT I'VE LEARNED
THE MOST FROM BEING
IN THIS COMPETITION
AND DEALING WITH LUPUS
IS THAT IT'S ABOUT MAINTAINING
MY DISEASE AND JUST--
I'M MENTALLY SO STRONG
THAT I'M NOT COMPLAINING AT ALL.
Yoanna: HEY, MAMA,
I GOT A CHANCE TO CALL YOU.
HOW ARE YOU?
I HAVEN'T TALKED TO YOU
IN SO LONG.
Yoanna's mom:
Oh, amorcita.
Yoanna: I GUESS I DIDN'T
REALIZE HOW LONELY
YOU CAN ACTUALLY GET
WHILE YOU'RE,
YOU KNOW,
DOING THIS.
YOU KNOW, I'M VERY CLOSE
WITH MY MOM,
SO IT'S REALLY
BEEN HARD BEING AWAY FROM HER.
I MISS YOU,
BUT...
Yoanna's mom: Okay,
you doing okay now?
Yoanna: MM-HMM.
(telephone rings)
Eric: Hi.
Shandi: HI.
Eric: I just wanted to say
that, um, I really--
I miss you a lot.
Shandi: AW.
I SERIOUSLY THOUGHT THAT
HE WOULD HATE ME FOREVER
FOR CHEATING.
Eric:
Can you sound happy?
Shandi: YEAH.
Eric: Honey,
I'm not mad, okay?
Shandi: OKAY.
Eric: I just care about you
right now, okay?
Shandi: EVEN THOUGH
IT'S A REALLY HORRIBLE THING
THAT I DID, IT SEEMS LIKE
WE'RE CLOSE ENOUGH
AND WE CARE ENOUGH
ABOUT EACH OTHER
THAT WE'RE
WILLING TO WORK THROUGH IT
AND, LIKE, DISCUSS IT
SO THAT WE CAN, YOU KNOW,
CONTINUE TO HAVE
A RELATIONSHIP.
Eric: Don't give up,
okay?
Shandi:
I WON'T.
Eric: I love you.
Shandi:
I LOVE YOU.
Mercedes: OH,
WE GOT TYRA MAIL, YOU GUYS.
Shandi: "NOW THAT THERE ARE
ONLY THREE OF YOU LEFT,
"COZY UP
INTO ONE ROOM."
Mercedes:
TOLD YOU!
Shandi:
(blows raspberry)
COME UPSTAIRS,
YOANNA.
Yoanna: OH, YOU'RE GONNA
COME OFFER AND HELP ME?
Shandi and Mercedes:
NO.
♪♪♪
Yoanna:
NOW THAT APRIL'S GONE,
I HAVE TO MOVE
ALL MY BELONGINGS UPSTAIRS,
AND NOBODY WANTS
TO HELP.
THEY JUST GO
STRAIGHT TO BED.
Shandi: WHAT IS THIS?
Mercedes: SHE'S BUSTING UP
OUR ROOM!
Yoanna: WELL, I COULD GET TO
SLEEP IF PEOPLE WOULD HELP ME!
Mercedes: WELL, DON'T BRING
SO DAMN MANY CLOTHES OUT.
Yoanna:
WHERE'S THE LOVE?
♪♪♪
Yoanna: TYRA MAIL.
WE GET A TYRA MAIL,
AND IT READS THAT WE'RE DOING
A BEAUTY AD TODAY.
"BE READY AT 10:30
IN THE MORNING.
"TYRA."
Mercedes: TODAY IT'S
SUPPOSED TO BE A BEAUTY SHOOT,
AND I DON'T LOOK GOOD.
♪♪♪
Shandi: I FEEL LIKE
RIGHT NOW
YOANNA IS
MY BIGGEST COMPETITION.
LIKE, SHE KNOWS HOW
TO WORK HER FACE.
SHE KNOWS EVERYTHING
ABOUT THIS BUSINESS.
SHE KNOWS
THE PHOTOGRAPHERS.
THE CLOTHES,
AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT I DON'T HAVE YET.
Yoanna: MERCEDES HAS GOT
A PRETTY GOOD SHOT
AT WINNING
THE COMPETITION.
YOU KNOW,
SHE PHOTOGRAPHS WELL.
SHE'S GOT
A GREAT PERSONALITY.
I THINK SHE'D BE
A GREAT ROLE MODEL,
A TOP MODEL.
Mercedes: I THINK SHANDI
WOULD BE MY BIGGEST COMPETITION.
SHE'S TRANSFORMED
SO MUCH
FROM A CATERPILLAR
TO A BUTTERFLY,
AND THE JUDGES
SEE THAT,
AND SHE REALLY WORKS WELL
IN HIGH FASHION.
THIS IS IT,
YOU KNOW?
THE LAST
PHOTO SHOOT.
Shandi:
AND IT'S KINDA SCARY
'CAUSE THERE'S NO ROOM
FOR MISTAKES.
Jay: GOOD MORNING,
GIRLS.
Yoanna: GOOD MORNING.
Jay: ALL THREE OF YOU
STANDING HERE
LOOK
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT,
BUT YOU'RE ALL SO BEAUTIFUL
IN YOUR OWN WAY.
SO TODAY EACH
AND EVERY ONE OF YOU
WILL GET
A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT LOOK.
TODAY'S SHOOT IS GONNA BE
HIGH-END, STYLIZED BEAUTY ADS.
Yoanna: DOING A BEAUTY AD
HAS BEEN, LIKE, MY DREAM
BECAUSE
ANY TOP MODEL,
LIKE, ONCE THEY GET
A COSMETIC CONTRACT,
LIKE, YOUR FACE BECOMES
A HOUSEHOLD NAME.
Jay: SO YOUR CREATIVE TEAM
TODAY--OBVIOUSLY,
EVIL UNCLE NOLé MARIN
WILL BE STYLING YOU TODAY.
GIAN LUCA GUAITOLI
WILL BE DOING YOUR HAIR,
AND OUR PHOTOGRAPHER
MASSIMO COSTOLI
WILL BE SHOOTING THESE
AMAZING BEAUTY ADS TODAY.
AS A MODEL,
YOUR SMILE IS SO IMPORTANT.
I JUST WANNA GIVE YOU
YOUR BRITESMILE WHITENING PEN.
JUST GO UP AND DOWN
ON ALL YOUR TEETH.
SO YOUR LOOK TODAY
IS GONNA BE THIS HELMET.
IT'S COOL, RIGHT?
Yoanna: VERY COOL.
Nolé: IT'S GORGEOUS.
Jay: AND YOU'RE SO STRONG
IN YOUR FACE,
THAT I THINK YOU
COULD TOTALLY CARRY THIS OFF.
Mercedes: THIS PHOTO SHOOT
IS GONNA DETERMINE A LOT FOR ME.
I NEED TO GET OUT
OF THAT COMMERCIAL LOOK.
Shandi: EACH ONE OF US
WANTS TO WIN THIS COMPETITION,
(laughing)
BUT I WANT IT MORE
THAN THEY DO
BECAUSE
I CAME THIS FAR, YOU KNOW?
Mercedes: I'M BUCKWHEAT
FROM "LITTLE RASCALS."
Nolé: IT'S GONNA BE
BEAUTIFUL.
Mercedes: I LOVE
NOLé'S FUNKINESS,
BUT HE PUT WIRE
AROUND ME,
AND I'M LIKE,
"YOU KNOW, HE'S THE STYLIST.
"HE KNOWS WHAT HE'S DOING,
YOU KNOW?
"SHUT YOUR MOUTH
AND BE QUIET."
♪♪♪
Yoanna: THE PRESSURE
HAS INCREASED,
I THINK ESPECIALLY
WITH THREE OF US JUST LEFT.
YOU HAVE TO REALLY,
YOU KNOW, PERFORM.
I'M JUST, LIKE,
WANTING EVERYTHING PERFECT.
MY HAIR AT THE BACK OF, LIKE,
MY NECK WAS ITCHING,
AND IT WAS COMING OUT
OF THE HELMET,
BUT GIAN LUCA DIDN'T HAVE
THE TIME TO DO IT.
CAN I HAVE
THE SCISSORS?
I'LL DO IT
MYSELF.
I'LL DO IT MYSELF.
(scissors snipping)
Yoanna: OH, NO.
Jay: YOANNA? UGH.
WHAT DID YOU DO?
Yoanna: DID I REALLY
BUTCHER IT?
Jay: YOU BUTCHERED IT.
YOU CUT A HUGE HOLE
IN THE BACK OF YOUR HEAD.
Yoanna: OH, MY GOSH.
Shandi: I CANNOT BELIEVE THAT
YOANNA CHOPPED HER HAIR,
AND IT LOOKS LIKE THERE'S
A BIG CHUNK
OUT OF THE BACK
OF HER HEAD.
Jay: YOANNA,
YOU'RE SO BEAUTIFUL.
STOP BEING ANXIOUS.
YOU'VE RUINED
YOUR HAIR.
I THINK IT MUST BE
THE COMPETITION.
YOANNA MIGHT BE
BREAKING DOWN INSIDE.
SHE NEEDS
TO GET IT TOGETHER.
♪♪♪
Mercedes: I THINK IT'S GREAT.
IT LOOKS LIKE AN AZTEC,
LIKE, WARRIOR,
ZULU AFRICAN THING.
I WAS
FEELING IT.
Massimo: GOOD.
Jay: MERCEDES,
YOU REALLY BLOW ME AWAY.
Mercedes: I WAS PICTURING THAT
THE CAMERA IS
THE EYES
OF YOANNA AND SHANDI
AND THAT THEY'RE NOT
GONNA TAKE ME DOWN.
I'M INVINCIBLE
LIKE SUPERWOMAN!
Shandi: WHEN I SEE MERCEDES
DOING HER PHOTOS,
SHE'S DOING
REALLY GOOD,
LIKE THOSE POSES
ARE AWESOME.
Massimo: I FINISH.
I GOT IT.
♪♪♪
Massimo: MORE STRONG
WITH YOUR EYES.
Shandi: THE PHOTO SHOOT
IS A TAD BIT DIFFICULT.
Massimo: GIVE A SMILE
WITH EYES.
Shandi: I HAVE A LOT OF
PROBLEMS WITH, LIKE,
SHOWING INTENSITY
AND, LIKE, FEELING IN MY EYES.
Mercedes: I WAS WATCHING
SHANDI, AND SHE HAD, LIKE,
A ROCK STAR'S TYPE OF
FEMININE APPEAL,
BUT WHEN I WAS LOOKING INTO
HER FACE, SHE LOOKED SCARED,
AND ALSO SHANDI KEPT ON
LOOKING AT ME IN THE BACKGROUND.
I'M LIKE, YES!
DISTRACTION!
(laughs)
Massimo: GOOD--
GOOD-- I LIKE THIS.
♪♪
Nolé: YOUR EARS OKAY?
♪♪♪
Massimo: GOOD.
RELAX THE MOUTH.
Yoanna: AND HE SAID,
"DON'T PUSH OUT THE LIPS
TOO MUCH,
"'CAUSE THEN YOU LOOK
LIKE YOU'RE... IT'S TOO POUTY.
"AND THEN GIVE THE EYES,
"BUT DON'T MAKE IT
TOO SQUINTY."
Massimo:
IT'S TOO MUCH DOWN.
Yoanna: AND THEN WHEN
YOU MOVE,
IT'S GOTTA BE
A CENTIMETER AT A TIME.
IT CAN'T BE NONE OF THIS
OR THAT.
I MEAN,
IT IS REALLY COMPLICATED.
I COULD BARELY HEAR ANYTHING
WITH THE HELMET ON.
Massimo: BELLA.
BRAVA.
I LIKE THIS.
Jay: YEAH, THERE YOU GO,
THERE YOU GO.
Mercedes: WATCHING YOANNA,
THEY WERE LIKE,
"OH, SHE'S BEAUTIFUL,
WONDERFUL."
THEY'RE LIKING HER,
AND I'M LIKE, "OH, BITCH,
YOU AIN'T GONNA GO NOWHERE."
SORRY.
(laughing)
Jay: WE GOT IT.
Massimo: FINISH.
Jay: YOU KNOW, IT'S DOWN
TO THE FINAL THREE GIRLS,
AND THEY'RE ALL
VERY STRONG.
SHANDI IS DOING
AMAZINGLY WELL.
MERCEDES JUST CONSTANTLY
SURPRISES ME,
AND YOANNA WANTS TO BE AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL SO BADLY.
Nolé: BIG CHUNK.
YOU GOT GUM
BACK THERE?
Jay: SHE'LL DO ANYTHING
TO WIN.
REALLY, RIGHT NOW IN TERMS OF
THE TOP THREE,
IT'S REALLY, REALLY,
REALLY, REALLY TIGHT.
♪♪♪
Yoanna: TYRA MAIL.
Shandi: HEY, LADIES!
"HAVE YOU REALLY LEARNED
ALL THE ELEMENTS
"IT TAKES
TO BE A TOP MODEL?
"YOU'LL BE MEETING
THE BROTHERS
"BEHIND THE MAJOR FASHION HOUSE
DSQUARED2."
Yoanna: DSQUARED2--
THEY'RE REALLY HIP.
Mercedes: THEIR CLIENTS
ARE, LIKE, EVE AND MADONNA,
AND THESE ARE ALL PEOPLE
THAT I ADMIRE.
Tyra: DSQUARED2 ARE
THE NEWEST, HOTTEST, HIPPEST
FASHION DESIGNERS
OF THE MOMENT
RIGHT NOW,
AND I'M SENDING
THE GIRLS TO DO
AN AUDITION
TO BE IN THE DSQUARED2
FINAL FASHION SHOW
FOR
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
♪♪♪
Yoanna and Mercedes:
THY KINGDOM COME
AND THY WILL BE DONE
ON EARTH AS IT IS IN HEAVEN...
Mercedes: THE PRESSURE NOW
IS EVEN HIGHER,
AND I'M JUST
TRYING TO STAY FOCUSED.
Shandi: MY COMPETITION
IS SO--IT'S FIERCE.
YOU CAN SEE IT
IN THEIR EYES.
WE ALL WANT IT,
AND IT'S COMING
DOWN TO THE FINAL COUNT NOW.
Dan: HELLO.
Mercedes: HOW ARE YOU?
I'M MERCEDES.
Dean: HI, LADIES.
I'M DEAN.
Dan: I'M DAN.
Dean: WE HAVE A LINE
CALLED DSQUARED2.
WE'VE DONE A LOT OF CASTINGS
AND A LOT OF THINGS,
AND NOW
WE'RE HERE TODAY...
Dan: TO SEE IF YOU GUYS
HAVE WHAT IT TAKES.
Shandi: DEAN AND DAN
KIND OF REMIND ME
OF, LIKE, LITTLE CHIPMUNKS
A LITTLE BIT.
Mercedes: THEY'RE LIKE
CHIP AND DALE,
AND THEY, LIKE, THEY COMPLETE
EACH OTHER'S SENTENCES.
Dean and Dan: SO...
All: (laughing)
Dean: WE'RE GONNA START
WITH YOU, MERCEDES.
Dan: PARK THE CAR.
Mercedes: ALL RIGHT.
Dean: WHY SHOULD WE BOOK YOU
AND NOT THE OTHER GIRLS
THAT ARE HERE TODAY
ON OUR CASTING?
Mercedes: YOU GUYS ARE FUN
AND FUNKY,
AND THAT'S THE TYPE
OF PERSON I AM,
AND TO FIND
A DESIGNER
THAT YOU CAN DO THAT WITH
IS GREAT.
Dean: MERCEDES--
HER PERSONALITY--
SHE'S A SWEET GIRL,
A BUBBLY GIRL.
MERCEDES WAS
GIVING IT.
Shandi: YOUR CLOTHING
IS REAL,
LIKE, IT BRINGS
INSPIRATION FROM REAL LIFE,
AND I CAN BRING
MY REALNESS AND MY ORIGINALITY.
Dean: SHANDI
IS A PALETTE.
Dan: YEAH,
SHE'S A BEAUTIFUL GIRL,
NICE POSTURE,
NICE LINES.
Yoanna: I'VE LOVED FASHION
ALL MY LIFE.
I GREW UP WATCHING ELSA KLENSCH
AT AGE 6,
AND, UH,
FORFEITED "SCOOBY-DOO."
I HAD MY FIRST--
Dean: "SCOOBY-DOO"...
Yoanna: I WAS LIKE,
"YEAH, I NEED ELSA."
Dean: YOANNA SEEMED
VERY PROFESSIONAL.
YOANNA REALLY LOVED FASHION,
I THINK.
YOU KNOW
WHAT I MEAN?
THEY HAD A LITTLE BIT
OF CULTURE IN FASHION.
NATURALLY WE'RE GONNA ASK YOU
WHO YOUR FAVORITE DESIGNER IS.
Yoanna: OH, WELL,
MARC JACOBS.
I'M SORRY.
Shandi: I LOVE
BETSEY JOHNSON.
Dean: (imitates buzzer)
Mercedes:
BETSEY JOHNSON?
Dean:
(imitates gun firing)
IF A DESIGNER
EVER ASKS YOU--
Yoanna: IT'S YOU.
I LOVE YOUR CLOTHES.
Dan: LEARN TO LIE.
Shandi: I THOUGHT YOU
REALLY WANTED TO KNOW.
NO, I'M JUST KIDDING.
Dan: NOBODY REALLY WANTS
TO KNOW ANYTHING.
♪♪♪
Jay: DEAN AND DAN
ARE GOING TO FIT YOU
IN SOME
OF THEIR CLOTHES
FOR SOMETHING THAT NOLé AND I
ARE PLANNING.
Dan: LET'S SEE IF YOU'RE
REALLY THESE GREAT BABES.
♪♪♪
Dan: A GIRL WHO ALWAYS
PUTS ON HER OWN CLOTHES,
OR HANGS THEM UP BY HERSELF
IS BETTER LOVED. (laughs)
I HATE THOSE BITCHES
THAT THROW IT ON THE FLOOR.
Mercedes: I THINK
THE LINE LOOKS BETTER ON ME
THAN ON YOANNA
AND SHANDI.
Dan: OOH.
Dean: HEY,
LET THEM HAPPEN.
Dan: YOU'RE
A SEXY DOLL.
Shandi: I'M, LIKE,
OH, MY GOD.
MERCEDES FITS PERFECTLY
IN THE CLOTHES.
Jay: MERCEDES
IS FEELING IT.
Shandi: YEAH, SHE'S GOT
EVERYTHING
THAT DSQUARED2
I THINK IS LOOKING FOR.
Dan: VERY GOOD.
GOOD WALKER,
GIRL.
END OF THE RUNWAY,
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA GIVE ME?
Yoanna: I'LL SAY WHATEVER
YOU WANT ME TO SAY.
I'LL DO WHATEVER
YOU WANT ME TO DO.
JUST BOOK ME.
Nolé: FABULOUS.
♪♪♪
Shandi: I DON'T WANT
A NEW ONE.
Mercedes: IT SAYS, "YOU HAVE
A VERY BIG DAY AHEAD OF YOU.
"TODAY YOU WILL MEET
WITH THE JUDGES,
"AND ONLY TWO OF YOU
WILL CONTINUE ON
"WITH THE HOPE OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
"ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED."
I AM NERVOUS,
I'M ANXIOUS.
IT'S A WHOLE BUNCH
OF EMOTIONS.
Shandi: I'M SHOCKED
BECAUSE
I DIDN'T EXPECT THE ELIMINATION
TO COME SO SOON.
Yoanna: I THINK THE REALITY
IS THAT THERE'S THREE OF US,
AND THERE IS
ONLY ONE PRIZE.
♪♪♪
Tyra: HELLO,
EVERYBODY.
Shandi: HI.
Tyra: IT'S TIME TO MAKE
OUR TENTH CUT,
WHICH WILL BRING US
ONE STEP CLOSER
TOWARDS DETERMINING
WHO WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL.
AND OF COURSE,
WE HAVE OUR JUDGES--
JANICE DICKINSON,
ERIC NICHOLSON
AND NIGEL BARKER.
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST,
WE HAVE OUR GUEST JUDGES--
DEAN AND DAN
OF DSQUARED2.
THEY'RE THE HOT THING
RIGHT NOW IN MILANO.
THEY ARE THE NEW AND THE NEXT
AND THE NOW.
I MEAN,
THEY'VE DONE EVERYBODY.
I MEAN...
Dean: THANK YOU.
(laughter)
Tyra: TONIGHT'S
A VERY SPECIAL ELIMINATION,
BECAUSE WHEN THE NIGHT
IS UP,
ONLY TWO OF YOU
WILL BE LEFT STANDING,
AND THOSE TWO WILL BE STARRING
IN A DSQUARED2 FASHION SHOW.
AND YOUR PERFORMANCE
IN THAT DSQUARED2 FASHION SHOW
WILL HELP DETERMINE
WHO WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
BUT NOW IT'S TIME FOR
YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS,
AND THEN THE JUDGES
WILL DELIBERATE,
AND WE'LL DETERMINE
WHICH ONE OF YOU
SHOULD BE
ELIMINATED.
AND, MERCEDES,
YOU'RE FIRST.
Dan: WALK FOR US.
♪♪♪
Tyra: WITH YOUR WALK,
MERCEDES, YOU GLIDE REALLY WELL,
BUT IT'S LIKE YOU HAVE ON
ROLLER SKATES.
YOU NEED TO PICK UP YOUR FEET
A BIT MORE
AND TAKE BIGGER STEPS.
YOU HAD A VERY EDGY BEAUTY SHOOT
WITH MASSIMO,
AND HERE IS
YOUR BEST SHOT.
Janice: BELLISSIMA.
Tyra: THAT'S GORGEOUS.
NEVER TOUCH YOUR FACE, GIRL,
OR I WILL COME AFTER YOU.
YOU ARE BEAUTIFUL.
Mercedes: THANK YOU.
Tyra: NOT MANY MODELS
CAN, LIKE,
THROW ON SOME NAPS
AND GREASE ON THEIR FACE
AND SOME WIRE
AND LOOK THAT FIERCE.
Nigel: I THINK
WITH THIS PICTURE,
YOU'VE ACTUALLY NAILED
THE BEAUTY.
Eric: I LIKE THE INTENSITY
OF YOUR STARE.
Dan: THIS IS PROVING
YOUR CHAMELEON QUALITIES
AS A MODEL,
WHICH IS AN IMPORTANT QUALITY.
Dean: ABSOLUTELY.
Dan: BRAVA.
Mercedes: OKAY,
THANK YOU.
Tyra:
NEXT IS SHANDI.
♪♪♪
Janice: I LOVE THE WAY
YOU LOOK.
YOUR ATTITUDE IS
SO HIP AND COOL.
YOU'VE COME
LIGHT-YEARS.
Eric: I THINK YOUR WALK
STILL NEEDS IMPROVEMENT.
Dean:
FEEL IT.
BELIEVE
YOURSELF.
Tyra: 'CAUSE I KNOW
THAT YOU HAVE IT IN YOU.
I DIDN'T SEE IT
TONIGHT,
BUT IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT ME
KNOWING IT,
IT'S ABOUT,
YOU KNOW,
EVERYONE SEEING THAT
YOU HAVE THAT.
ALL RIGHTY,
SHANDI,
SO YOU HAD AN EDGY PHOTO SHOOT
WITH MASSIMO,
AND HERE'S
YOUR BEST SHOT.
Janice: VERY MARY QUANT.
VERY GIRL NEXT DOOR
IN MOMMY'S PAINT.
IT'S A VERY LOVELY
PICTURE.
Nigel: YOU ARE
THE CANVAS,
AND YOU CAN BE
TRANSFORMED,
AND YOUR FACE IS--
IT TAKES MAKEUP
VERY WELL,
AS YOU CAN SEE HERE.
Eric: I STILL SEE
IN THIS PICTURE, THOUGH,
THAT THERE'S THAT QUESTION MARK
OF, YOU KNOW,
"SHANDI,
WE'RE GONNA MAKE YOU A STAR,"
AND IN YOUR EYES,
I THINK I STILL SEE
THAT, LIKE,
"ARE YOU GONNA
MAKE ME A STAR?"
Tyra: NEXT IS YOANNA.
Dean: WALK FOR US,
HONEY.
♪♪♪
Dan: NOT GOOD.
NOT BAD.
I THINK YOU DEFINITELY NEED
TO FOCUS ON YOUR STYLE.
Nigel: THE WALK, FOR ME
AS WELL, WAS A LITTLE STIFF.
Eric: THIS WAS SORT OF YOU
DOING A CONVENTIONAL WALK.
Tyra: AND HERE IS
YOUR BEST SHOT.
Janice:
MOON ROCKET GIRL.
YOUR EYES
ARE AMAZING.
YOUR LIPS
ARE PERFECTION.
WELL DONE.
Tyra: IT LOOKS LIKE
YOU'RE A VILLAIN IN A MOVIE,
AND YOU'RE CHASING
THE GOOD GUYS ON A MOTORCYCLE.
Janice: YEAH.
Tyra: LIKE YOU HAVE
AN ACCENT
(foreign accent)
AND YOU TALK LIKE THIS.
(normal voice) I MEAN, YOANNA,
YOUR PICTURE IS BEAUTIFUL,
BUT DO YOU KNOW WHAT IT MEANS
IF YOU'RE NOT A CLUTCH ATHLETE?
LIKE A CLUTCH PLAYER?
Yoanna: YEAH.
Tyra: WHEN IT'S
THE CHAMPIONSHIP,
AND THERE'S FIVE SECONDS LEFT,
HE SCREWS UP,
AND THAT'S WHAT
I FEEL YOU ARE.
YOU HAVE THE STRONGEST WALK
TO ME,
BUT THEN YOU GET HERE,
DOWN TO THE WIRE
AND FALL
TO PIECES.
♪♪♪
Tyra: ALL RIGHT,
SO NOW IT'S TIME TO DELIBERATE.
Dean: WONDER TWIN POWER.
Nigel: I MEAN, I DID A CASTING
SINCE I WAS HERE IN MILAN
FOR SOMETHING
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT,
AND ANY ONE OF THESE GIRLS
WOULD HAVE BEEN BETTER
THAN A LOT OF THE GIRLS
WHO I SAW HERE.
SO WE'RE REALLY ONTO
THE RIGHT THING,
WHICH IS GREAT.
Tyra: YOANNA.
Dean: A PICTURE SPEAKS
A THOUSAND WORDS.
THIS GIRL
IS GIVING YOU FACE.
Eric: SHE CAN HAVE
A HELMET ON HER HEAD
AND LOOK AMAZING.
SHE'S JUST
AN INCREDIBLE BEAUTY.
Nigel: BUT YOU KNOW,
ALMOST LIKE THIS PICTURE
IS A HEAD, YOU KNOW?
DOES SHE HAVE THE REST
OF THE PACKAGE?
AND I'M NOT SURE.
Tyra: WHEN I LOOK
AT YOANNA,
I SEE SOMEONE THAT LIVES
AND BREATHES FASHION.
I REALLY ADMIRE
THAT DESIRE.
UM, I'M NOT IMPRESSED BY THE
FACT THAT SHE'S NOT CONSISTENT.
MERCEDES.
Janice:
OF THE THREE GIRLS,
SHE WON THE WALKING COMPETITION
THIS EVENING.
HER BODY IS AMAZING.
Eric: FOR ME, IT'S THESE LIFE
EXPERIENCES THAT SHE'S HAD
IS WHY SHE'S MAKING A PHOTOGRAPH
THAT SAYS SOMETHING MORE THAN,
"MY FACE LOOKS NICE
WITH MAKEUP ON IT."
Nigel: HERE YOU CAN SEE
THAT SHE CAN DO BEAUTY,
AND SHE CAN DO
THE COMMERCIAL CATALOG STUFF.
Tyra: I MEAN, IF THIS CAN
WALK AROUND ALL THE TIME
AND DO INTERVIEWS
AND DO FASHION SHOWS
AND LOOK LIKE THIS...
SHANDI, NIGEL.
Nigel:
SHANDI IS IN FOR ME,
'CAUSE I THINK PHOTOGRAPHICALLY
SHE HAS WHAT IT TAKES.
Eric: THERE'S SOMETHING THAT
HAS MAYBE STALLED WITH HER.
Tyra: SHANDI IS WHAT
MODELS ARE ABOUT NOW.
UP AND COMING MODELS
DON'T LOOK LIKE ME.
THEY HAVE AN EDGE THAT JUST
CONFUSES PEOPLE A LITTLE BIT,
AND I LIKE HER BEING THERE
FOR THAT REASON.
Janice: BUT SHE SHOULD LEARN
HOW TO WALK.
SHANDI HAS NOT BEEN ABLE
TO WALK.
YES, SHANDI LOOKS GREAT
IN CLOTHES.
Nigel: YEAH,
I MEAN, COME ON.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
A FASHION MODEL.
SHE'S GOTTA
WEAR CLOTHES.
I MEAN,
I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
(laughter)
Tyra: NOW, ALL RIGHT,
YOU GUYS.
COME ON,
THIS IS SERIOUS.
WHICH ONE OF THESE GIRLS DO YOU
THINK SHOULD BE SENT HOME?
Janice:
(sighs) IT'S HARD.
Nigel: MY GOODNESS, GUYS.
Eric: THIS REALLY
IS HARD.
Janice: IT'S REALLY HARD.
MY HEAD.
UGH.
Tyra: THERE ARE
THREE BEAUTIFUL GIRLS
WITH THREE VERY DIFFERENT
STRENGTHS
STANDING IN FRONT
OF ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE TWO PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS,
AND THESE TWO PHOTOS
REPRESENT
THE TWO BEAUTIFUL WOMEN
THAT WILL GO HEAD TO HEAD
AND COMPETE
IN A DSQUARED2 FASHION SHOW
TO BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Tyra: MERCEDES.
MERCEDES, YOU HAVE
COME SO FAR.
YOU WENT FROM,
"OH, I'M A COMMERCIAL GIRL"
TO, "YEAH, I MIGHT LOOK
A LITTLE COMMERCIAL IN PERSON,
BUT I'LL SHOW YOU EDGE."
AND THIS PICTURE RIGHT HERE
SAVED YOUR ASS, GIRL,
'CAUSE IF YOU HAD A HINT
OF A SMILE IN YOUR EYE,
YOU PROBABLY WOULD'VE BEEN
GOING HOME TONIGHT.
BUT THIS ONE PICTURE JUST PUT
THE EXCLAMATION POINT ON,
"I CAN BE EDGY,
AND I WILL BE EDGY."
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU ARE ONE
OF THE FINALISTS.
(laughing)
Mercedes: THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
Tyra: WILL SHANDI AND YOANNA
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
THERE ARE TWO OF YOU
STANDING IN FRONT OF ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS.
BOTH OF YOU HAVE DONE SO WELL
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS.
YOANNA, YOU STARTED OFF PRETTY
STRONG AND VERY KNOWLEDGEABLE.
YOU WERE DOING
YOUR THING
AND PROVING TO US WEEK TO WEEK
HOW GREAT YOU WALKED,
HOW ORIGINAL
YOU WERE,
HOW GORGEOUS
YOUR PICTURES WERE.
SHANDI, YOU STARTED OFF
KINDA WEAK,
BUT THEN SHOWED US
THAT YOU CAN BE EDGY,
THAT YOU CAN BE
BEAUTIFUL,
AND THEN TODAY,
BOTH OF YOU
FELL APART IN THIS ROOM.
WHAT ARE YOU
GONNA DO
WHEN THERE'S LIGHTS, CAMERA,
ACTION,
AND PEOPLE YELLING
YOUR NAME
AND FLASHBULBS
GOING OFF ON THAT RUNWAY,
AND THE AUDIENCE LOOKING AT YOU
AND SCRUTINIZING YOU,
AND THE DRESSERS
PULLING AT YOU
AND THE PERSON IS PUSHING YOU
OUT ON THE RUNWAY AND SAYING,
"SHANDI, GO!
YOANNA, GO!"?
IF YOU CAN'T HANDLE THESE
SIX PEOPLE LOOKING AT YOU,
HOW ARE YOU GONNA
HANDLE THAT?
I WILL ONLY CALL
ONE NAME,
AND THE NAME THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY RETURN
TO YOUR ITALIAN APARTMENT
AND PACK YOUR BAGS AND GO HOME.
Tyra: YOANNA.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOANNA,
YOU ARE A FINALIST.
THANKS, SHANDI.
Shandi: OH, MY GOD.
LIKE, AT SOME POINTS,
I JUST LOOK IN THE MIRROR.
I DON'T EVEN
RECOGNIZE MYSELF.
IT'S HARD TO EVEN TRY
TO REMEMBER HOW I USED TO BE,
AND I FEEL LIKE I'VE GROWN
SO MUCH,
AND IT'S LIKE,
I'VE GROWN INTO A PERSON THAT
I LIKE AND I APPRECIATE MORE.
NOW WHEN I GET HOME,
I WON'T FEEL SO LOST, YOU KNOW?
I WON'T FEEL SO...
INSECURE ABOUT MYSELF,
WHICH I THINK IS THE BEST THING
I'M GONNA TAKE OUT OF THIS.
AND, LIKE, I HAVE
A REALLY GOOD FEELING THAT
MY BOYFRIEND AND I
ARE STILL GONNA WORK
AND THAT WE'RE GONNA
MAKE IT WORK,
AND THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
TOGETHER.
♪♪♪
Mercedes: "SHANDI MAIL.
"TO YOANNA
AND MERCEDES."
Yoanna: "THANK YOU
FOR TAKING CARE OF ME
"DURING ONE OF THE ROUGHEST
MOMENTS OF MY LIFE.
"I LOVE YOU, TOO."
IT'S BITTERSWEET NOT HAVING
SHANDI IN THE HOUSE.
I LOVE HER DEARLY
AS A FRIEND,
BUT SHE'S
MY COMPETITOR,
AND IT'S LIKE, THIS JUST GETS ME
ONE STEP CLOSER
TO HAVING MY DREAM
FULFILLED.
"WITH LOVE AND BEST WISHES,
SHANDAI."
Mercedes: "A.K.A.
THE EVIL SHANDAR."
IT'S HITTING ME NOW THAT
IT'S JUST GONNA BE YOANNA AND I
FIGHTING FOR
THAT NUMBER ONE,
AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
SHE AIN'T GONNA
TAKE MY TITLE.
YOANNA AND I ARE GOING
TO A GALLERIA WITH TYRA.
Yoanna: OH, MY GOSH.
Mercedes: OH, WOW.
Tyra: UH-OH!
THIS IS WHERE YOU GUYS
ARE GONNA DO YOUR RUNWAY,
YOUR FASHION SHOW
FOR DSQUARED2.
Mercedes: I'M LIKE,
OH, MY GOD.
I SEE, LIKE,
EVERYBODY SETTING UP THE RUNWAY.
THERE'S LIGHTS,
THERE'S PEOPLE,
AND THEY'RE
VERY SERIOUS,
AND I JUST STARTED
TO GET NERVOUS.
Yoanna: I'M SO EXCITED.
I MEAN, TO ACTUALLY BE DOING
A REAL RUNWAY SHOW IN MILAN--
I JUST FEEL THAT
I'M ALMOST THERE,
AND IT'S JUST, LIKE,
THIS IS THE LAST OBSTACLE,
AND IT'S LIKE,
I WANNA GIVE IT MY ALL,
AND I'M EAGER TO,
YOU KNOW,
REALLY GET OUT THERE
AND KICK SOME ASS.
Tyra: DON'T LOOK AT ANYBODY
EXCEPT STRAIGHT AHEAD.
YOU'LL FEEL ALL THESE FLASHES
OF PHOTOGRAPHERS,
AND FEEL THAT
AND TAKE THAT IN.
Jay: THIS IS
A REAL FASHION SHOW,
SO YOU'VE GOTTA REALIZE NOW
THIS IS THE REAL DEAL.
IT'S NOT JUST
THE MERCEDES AND YOANNA SHOW.
IT'S THE DSQUARED2 SHOW.
♪♪♪
Jay: OKAY,
20 MINUTES, GIRLS.
Yoanna: IT'S FUN AND EXCITING
BEING BACK THERE.
IT'S LIKE,
OH, MY GOSH,
THE CLOTHES ARE, LIKE,
PHENOMENAL.
THERE'S A TON
OF PEOPLE.
WE'VE GOT GIRLS
WHO THINK
THEY'RE JUST, LIKE,
THE CRèME DE LA CRèME.
Woman: IT'S YOUR
FIRST SHOW!
Mercedes: BUT THIS IS THE SHOW
THAT REALLY COUNTS FOR ME.
AND I ASKED THEM,
"HAVE YOU DONE SHOWS
LIKE THIS?"
AND THEY'RE LIKE,
(foreign accent) "OH, YES.
(scoffs) SINCE I'VE BEEN 12
OR SOMETHING."
(normal voice)
AND I'M LIKE, OH --.
♪♪♪
Jay: FIVE MINUTES
TO SHOW.
I NEED YOU
IN YOUR FIRST OUTFITS.
Yoanna: THE LAST COUPLE TIMES
THAT I'VE BEEN NERVOUS,
ESPECIALLY IN FRONT OF
THE JUDGES, HAS BEEN THE WALK.
IT HAS GOOFED ME UP,
AND I GOOFED UP YESTERDAY,
SO HOPEFULLY I'LL MAKE UP
FOR IT WITH TODAY.
Mercedes: SO I'M LOOKING
IN THE AUDIENCE
AND I'M SAYING,
"OH, MY GOD.
THERE'S, LIKE,
300 PEOPLE HERE."
Dan: REMEMBER,
AT THE END OF THE RUNWAY,
TAKE YOUR TIME.
GIVE THEM
A POSE.
Yoanna: THIS IS IT,
THIS IS THE RUNWAY FINAL,
END OF
THE COMPETITION.
Mercedes: MY HEART
IS PUMPING SO FAST.
IT'S--
I MEAN, IT'S INCREDIBLE
THAT I DIDN'T HAVE
A PANIC ATTACK.
Jay: FIVE... FOUR...
THREE... TWO... ONE.
Yoanna: TONIGHT IS, LIKE,
A CRITICAL TURNING POINT
OF WHERE THE COMPETITION
WILL GO.
Mercedes: I'M REALLY NERVOUS.
LIKE,
I'M TREMBLING.
MY STOMACH IS, LIKE,
DOING BUTTERFLIES.
Tyra: THIS IS THE ULTIMATE TEST
FOR THE GIRLS.
THERE'S NO ROOM
FOR, "I'M AN AMATEUR."
ARE YOU A TOP MODEL,
OR ARE YOU NOT?
TONIGHT WILL PROVE WHO IS.
♪♪♪
(cheers and applause)
Jay: WORK IT OUT,
YOANNA.
IT'S YOUR MOMENT.
Yoanna: I'M NOT AWARE
OF THE AUDIENCE.
I'M TRYING
TO LOOK SEXY.
IT WAS LIKE A HIGH,
LIKE AN ADRENALINE RUSH.
♪♪♪
Tyra: WHOO!
Mercedes: EVERYBODY'S
PULLING, TUGGING.
PEOPLE ARE CLAPPING,
AND I'M LIKE,
AAH!
OH, MY GOD!
THIS IS TOO MUCH!
♪♪♪
Tyra: GO, MERCEDES!
♪ ONE MORE TIME
DO IT AGAIN NOW ♪
DO IT AGAIN NOW... ♪
Jay: ALL RIGHT,
SIT DOWN IF YOU HAVE TO DO IT.
GET BACK OUT THERE.
♪ ONE MORE TIME
DO IT AGAIN NOW ♪
♪ DO IT AGAIN,
DO IT AGAIN... ♪
Jay: YOANNA! YOANNA!
♪♪♪
Tyra: YOU BETTER WORK,
GIRL!
Jay: WHERE'S MERCEDES?
Dan: MERCEDES!
Mercedes: HERE I GO,
AND I'M WALKING,
AND THEN I'M LIKE,
"OH. OH, THAT'S YOANNA?
OH... THAT BITCH."
AND THEN I DO
MY POSE,
AND I GO, "YEAH,
THIS ONE'S FOR YOANNA."
MM-MM-MM-MM.
Tyra: WHOO!
WORK IT OUT!
IT IS
REALLY DANGEROUS.
THERE'S A TON OF PEOPLE
BACK THERE.
MY HEEL BROKE.
THEY HAD TO GO AND FIND
ANOTHER SHOE.
ONE SHOE
DID NOT FIT.
I THINK IT WAS, LIKE,
FOUR SIZES TOO SMALL.
Mercedes:
PULL THE CHAIR.
Jay: I NEED A MODEL!
Dan: YOANNA?
NO,
YOU'RE MERCEDES.
MERCEDES,
LET'S GO.
♪♪♪
♪ YOU GOTTA ROCK TO THE RHYTHM
WITH 'EM ♪
♪ GOT TO GIVE IT
TO THEM ♪
♪ GOT TO GIVE A LOT ♪
♪ MORE THAN
THE MINIMUM ♪
♪ WALK TO THE RHYTHM
WITH 'EM ♪
♪ GOT TO GIVE IT
TO 'EM ♪
♪ GOT TO GIVE A LOT ♪
♪ MORE, MORE... ♪
Nolé: YOANNA,
WE NEED TO GET GOING.
Yoanna: I KNOW--
HE'S GETTING ME SHOES.
MY SHOES BROKE.
Jay: I JUST NEED YOANNA.
Yoanna: NOLé FOUND
MERCEDES' OLD SHOES,
SO THEY SAID, "OKAY,
YOU JUST HAVE TO WORK IT."
Nolé: SCRUNCH YOUR TOES.
Jay: YOANNA!
Yoanna: SO I JUST
WENT OUT THERE
AND DID THE BEST
THAT I COULD.
♪ COME ON ♪
♪ YOU GOTTA WALK
TO THE RHYTHM WITH 'EM ♪
♪ GOT TO GIVE IT
TO 'EM ♪
♪ GOT TO GIVE A LOT ♪
♪ MORE
THAN THE MINIMUM ♪
♪ WALK TO THE RHYTHM
WITH 'EM ♪
♪ GOT TO GIVE IT
TO 'EM ♪
♪ GOT TO GIVE A LOT ♪
♪ MORE, MORE ♪
♪ ROCK TO THE RHYTHM
WITH 'EM... ♪
Tyra: I HAVE NO IDEA WHO'S
GONNA WIN THIS COMPETITION.
BOTH GIRLS
WORKED IT.
BOTH GIRLS ROCKED IT.
♪ GOT TO GIVE IT
TO 'EM ♪
♪ GOT TO GIVE A LOT ♪
♪ MORE, MORE ♪♪
Jay: GREAT JOB,
YOANNA.
PHENOMENAL JOB.
Yoanna and Mercedes:
AAH!
Jay: OH, MY GOD.
HEY, GIRLS,
YOU GUYS SO ROCKED.
I DON'T KNOW
HOW WE DID IT.
Yoanna: THE SHOES BROKE.
I HAD TO WEAR
NEW ONES.
I DID MAKE DO WITH THE SHOES
THAT I WORE
THAT I WASN'T
SUPPOSED TO WEAR,
AND I WAS
FREAKED OUT.
Jay: MERCEDES,
LET ME JUST
GIVE YOU A HUG.
Mercedes: I'M JUST
REALLY HAPPY TO BE HERE.
I FELT SEXY,
SO HOPEFULLY,
WHEN I SEE THE VIDEO
AND THE PICTURES,
HOPEFULLY
THAT'S WHAT IT EMOTES.
Mercedes and Yoanna:
(laugh)
Yoanna: WE HAVE
TYRA MAIL.
Mercedes: WE DO?
WE'LL OPEN IT
TOGETHER.
Yoanna: OKAY,
I'LL TEAR ONE SIDE,
AND YOU TEAR
THE OTHER.
"TOMORROW THE JUDGES
WILL DETERMINE
"WHO WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
"GOOD LUCK,
LADIES."
THIS WHOLE EXPERIENCE
HAS BEEN PHENOMENAL.
I JUST FEEL
SO BLESSED.
LIKE, I NEVER THOUGHT THAT
GOD WOULD GIVE ME THIS MUCH.
WE'LL HAVE A GOOD BREAKFAST
TOMORROW, AND THEN WE'LL GET...
(imitating Janice) "WHAT
THE HELL WERE YOU THINKING?
"YOU WERE STUPID,
GIRL!
"WE WERE CREATING TOP MODELS,
NOT CLOWNS ON THE RUNWAY."
Mercedes: THIS IS,
LIKE,
WHAT I'VE BEEN WORKING TOWARDS
MY WHOLE LIFE, YOU KNOW,
AND TO EVEN FATHOM THAT I CAN
POSSIBLY GET WHAT I WANT,
YOU KNOW, GOING ALL THE WAY,
AND JUST FEELING ALL THAT,
I'M JUST TITILLATED ABOUT
THE WHOLE SITUATION.
♪♪♪
Mercedes: IT'S SO WEIRD.
THIS WHOLE JOURNEY IS OVER.
Yoanna: I KNOW!
IS THIS REALLY
OUR LAST DAY?
SEEMS LIKE WE'RE GONNA PACK UP
AND GO SOMEWHERE ELSE.
I THINK MERCEDES IS
A BEAUTIFUL PERSON,
AND I LOVE HER
SO MUCH,
BUT I WOULD BE
REALLY HEARTBROKEN
IF MERCEDES WON,
BECAUSE I'VE WANTED IT
FOR SO LONG
SINCE I WAS
A LITTLE GIRL,
SO I'M GONNA BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Mercedes: DID YOU GET
EVERYTHING?
Yoanna: YEAH.
Mercedes: JUST LET ME KNOW
WHEN YOU'RE READY.
YOANNA IS
A GREAT PERSON.
I MEAN, I'VE SHARED
A LOT WITH HER,
BUT IF YOANNA WINS,
I'M GONNA PULL OUT HER HAIR
AND SAY, "IT WASN'T--
IT WASN'T MEANT TO BE!
I SWEAR,
IT WASN'T MEANT TO BE!"
I'LL KILL HER.
(laughing)
I'LL TAKE YOU
OUT OF THIS COMPETITION.
Yoanna: (British accent)
I'M READY.
Mercedes: (British accent)
ALL RIGHTY, THEN.
Yoanna: MERCEDES...
Mercedes: WE SHALL PART.
♪♪♪
Mercedes: ONWARD MARCH.
Tyra: HI, LADIES.
WE'VE WATCHED YOU TRANSFORM
FROM EVERYDAY LITTLE GIRLS
TO REAL,
BONA FIDE MODELS.
AND NOW IT'S TIME
FOR ONLY ONE OF YOU
TO GRADUATE TO THE REAL WORLD
OF MODELING
AS AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL.
AMONG THE PRIZES
THAT THE WINNER WILL RECEIVE
ARE A CONTRACT
WITH IMG MODELS,
A FASHION SPREAD
IN "JANE" MAGAZINE
AND A COSMETICS CAMPAIGN
WITH SEPHORA.
AND FOR THE FINAL TIME
IN THIS COMPETITION,
I'M GOING TO INTRODUCE
OUR PANEL OF JUDGES.
FIRST IS ONE OF THE WORLD'S
FIRST SUPERMODELS,
MISS JANICE DICKINSON.
WE HAVE ALSO
ERIC NICHOLSON,
WHO IS THE SENIOR FASHION EDITOR
OF "JANE" MAGAZINE.
AND LAST
BUT NOT LEAST,
WE HAVE
MR. NIGEL BARKER,
A NOTED FASHION
PHOTOGRAPHER,
AND HE ALSO PHOTOGRAPHED YOU ALL
IN YOUR VERY FIRST SHOOT.
THERE IS NO GUEST JUDGE
TONIGHT
BECAUSE WE HAVE SEEN YOU
FROM WEEK TO WEEK,
WHEREAS A GUEST JUDGE
ONLY COMES IN FOR ONE WEEK.
SO WE FEEL LIKE WE KNOW YOU
BETTER THAN ANYBODY
IN THE WHOLE ENTIRE WORLD
RIGHT NOW
WHEN IT COMES TO DECIDING
WHO HAS WHAT IT TAKES
TO BE A STAR.
NOW IT'S TIME FOR
YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS.
AND THEN AFTER THAT,
THE JUDGES WILL DELIBERATE
AND WILL DETERMINE WHICH ONE
OF YOU ALL WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL.
NOW YOU GUYS KNOW
THAT YOU WALKED
IN A VERY, VERY
IMPORTANT FASHION SHOW,
AND WE HAVE GOT
THAT FOOTAGE.
Eric: IT WAS SO GREAT.
Janice: THAT WAS THE ATTITUDE
OF A TOP MODEL, BABY.
Nigel: MERCEDES,
NICE TO SEE YOU TAKING
YOUR LITTLE SIGNATURE WALK
THAT YOU SEEM TO HAVE,
AND YOU'VE JUST
REFINED IT ENOUGH.
YOU WERE FIERCE LAST NIGHT,
MERCEDES.
Janice: YEAH,
SHE'S WORKING IT,
LITTLE BOOTY THERE.
YOUR ASS
IS SO CUTE!
♪♪♪
Eric: YOU WERE SO GOOD
AT THE END,
MAKING A CONNECTION
WITH THE PHOTOGRAPHER.
Tyra: YOU GUYS MIXED IN WITH THE
EXPERIENCED MODELS FLAWLESSLY.
Eric: ABSOLUTELY.
Tyra: WELL, HOW DID YOU FEEL
ON THE RUNWAY, YOANNA?
Yoanna: OH, I'VE NEVER
DONE DRUGS,
BUT I'M SURE IT WOULD
BE LIKE DOING SOME SORT OF DRUG.
IT WAS NERVE-RACKING, TOO,
BECAUSE MY SHOE BROKE.
Janice: OH, MY GOD.
Yoanna: I HAD TO BORROW
MERCEDES' SHOES.
Janice: SOMETIMES SOME OF THE
GIRLS AREN'T THAT GENEROUS WITH,
"HERE, BORROW MY SHOES"--
NO WAY.
Tyra: ONE THING I NOTICED,
YOANNA, THAT YOU DID,
IS YOU WERE ON THE RIBBON,
BUT TOO MUCH.
AND THEN, MERCEDES,
IN THE END, REMEMBER,
I TOLD YOU DO AT THE MOST,
TWO POSES?
YOU DID ABOUT FIVE
ONE TIME.
SO THAT WAS
A BIT MUCH.
ALL RIGHTY, NOW WE'RE GONNA
TAKE A LOOK
AT THE BEST
OF YOUR PHOTOGRAPHS
FROM ALL
OF YOUR PHOTO SHOOTS.
AND HERE IS
THE FIRST.
Nigel: I LOVE THEM,
OF COURSE.
YOU WERE BOTH EXTREMELY
PROFESSIONAL ON MY SETS.
Tyra: FOR YOUR VERY FIRST
PHOTO SHOOT,
YOU ALL WERE
REALLY AMAZING.
Janice: YOUR FACES
ARE FLAWLESS IN THE PICTURES.
Eric: I MEAN, THEY BOTH
WERE STRIKING.
I THINK THIS IS WHERE WE FIRST
WERE SEEING POTENTIAL.
Janice: OH!
Nigel: MM-HMM.
YOU BOTH
LOOK GORGEOUS.
Eric: YOU'RE LIKE
YING AND YANG HERE--
HARD AND SOFT,
MASCULINE AND FEMININE.
Nigel: YOANNA, I ACTUALLY--
YOU LOOK FANTASTIC HERE.
I MEAN,
THIS IS YOUR GENRE.
Janice: MERCEDES,
I LOVE THIS PICTURE OF YOU.
Tyra: I LIKE HOW HER LITTLE BABY
HAIRS JUST, LIKE, SMOOTH DOWN.
THAT'S A GHETTO THING.
ONLY LITTLE GHETTO GIRLS
WILL UNDERSTAND.
Janice: HUH?
Tyra: IT'S A
GHETTO THING, JANICE.
THESE ARE THE PICTURES WHERE
YOANNA WAS AUDREY HEPBURN
AND MERCEDES
WAS BILLIE HOLIDAY.
I WAS COACHING
EVERYONE ON SET,
AND I DIDN'T HAVE TO GIVE
EITHER OF YOU A LOT OF INPUT.
YOU GUYS
REALLY NAILED THIS.
Eric: I HAVE TO SAY
THE SOPHISTICATION IN YOUR EYES,
MERCEDES, IS VERY GOOD
FOR BILLIE HOLIDAY.
Nigel: THESE
ARE BEAUTIFUL.
REALLY,
THESE TWO
ARE SOME OF THE BEST PICTURES
YOU GUYS HAVE TAKEN.
Janice: IT'S "VOGUE"
AND "BREAKFAST AT TIFFANY'S."
Nigel: MERCEDES,
I LOVE YOUR HANDS.
I LIKE
THE WARRIOR-LIKE STYLE.
THE ONE OF YOU, YOANNA,
IS A LITTLE COMMERCIAL.
IT'S A LITTLE SORT
OF CATALOG.
Tyra: CATALOG.
I THINK FACE,
YOANNA,
YOU'RE STRONGER IN THIS PICTURE
THAN MERCEDES,
BUT FULL-LENGTH,
MERCEDES IS STRONGER
THAN YOANNA.
Janice: IT IS THE MOST
DIFFICULT THING ON THE PLANET
TO TAKE YOUR CLOTHES OFF
AND POSE
IN FRONT
OF PEOPLE PASSING BY,
SO WELL DONE.
Nigel: YOANNA,
PREVIOUS WEEKS,
I WASN'T GETTING THAT
SEX APPEAL THING.
Yoanna: I THOUGHT
OF YOU.
Nigel: YOU KNOW, WELL,
I'M GLAD YOU--
Eric: I LOVE HER.
Tyra: THAT'S WHO YOU WERE
THINKING ABOUT.
Yoanna: 'CAUSE HE NEVER
THINKS I'M SEXY.
Janice: SHE JUST WANTS YOU
TO VOTE FOR HER.
♪♪♪
Eric: YOANNA, YOUR FACE
IS INCREDIBLY SYMMETRICAL.
Janice: MERCEDES, I'M CRAZY
ABOUT YOUR PICTURE HERE.
CRAZY.
Tyra: YOANNA'S, TO ME,
LOOKS LIKE A MAGAZINE COVER.
AND, MERCEDES, YOURS IS JUST
LIKE A BEAUTY STORY.
Nigel: I THINK BOTH OF YOU
GUYS REALLY ROCKED THIS OUT.
YOU'VE TAKEN ALL YOUR PREVIOUS
WEEKS' EXPERIENCE
AND PUT IT
TOGETHER,
AND YOU'VE
ALL GROWN,
AND HERE IT IS,
YOUR FINAL
PHOTOGRAPH,
AND IT'S COME TOGETHER
FOR BOTH OF YOU,
WHICH IS
BRILLIANT.
Tyra: OKAY, SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR NIGEL AND ERIC
AND JANICE AND MYSELF
TO DELIBERATE,
AND WHEN
YOU COME BACK,
I WILL ANNOUNCE WHO WILL BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL, OKAY?
OKAY, THANKS.
Mercedes: THANK YOU.
Yoanna: THANKS.
Janice: I SEE
MERCEDES WORKING
IN EVERY COUNTRY
ON EARTH.
SHE WAS
THE STRONGEST
IN THE RUNWAY COMPETITION
FOR ME.
Eric: I THINK YOANNA,
FOR ME,
MAKES MORE OF AN IMPRESSION
IN AN EXCITING WAY.
Tyra: I THINK YOANNA'S FACE
IS SO STRIKING.
SHE LIVES AND BREATHES
THE MODELING.
THE DESIGNERS.
AND YOANNA KNOWS IT,
AND I'M REALLY IMPRESSED
BY THAT.
Nigel: BUT THE THING IS
MERCEDES HAS THAT PERSONALITY
WHICH, YOU KNOW,
YOU WANNA BOOK,
AND SHE CAN MOVE
REALLY WELL.
Eric: I THINK YOANNA
HAS THE "X" FACTOR IN HER,
WHICH IS
I'M NOT REALLY SURE
WHAT'S GONNA COME OUT
OF HER MOUTH,
OR I'M NOT REALLY SURE
WHAT SHE'S GONNA DO
IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA,
AND THAT'S EXCITING.
Tyra: YEAH, BUT MERCEDES
HAS THAT PERSONALITY
THAT IS A TOP MODEL
PERSONALITY,
AND SHE'S FIGHTING
A DISEASE.
SHE HAS THESE THINGS
AND THESE EXPERIENCES
THAT YOU LOOK
AT THIS SWEET GIRL
AND YOU GO, "WOW,
I DIDN'T KNOW THAT."
Janice: THAT'S WHY
I LOVE MERCEDES.
I THINK MERCEDES
IS A SURVIVOR.
SHE'S BLOWING ME
AWAY.
Nigel: SHE REALLY WAS ONE
OF THE BEST GIRLS
ON THE RUNWAY
YESTERDAY,
BUT THE THING IS,
IS DOES SHE HAVE
THE FACE
TO, SORT OF, GRAB
INTERNATIONAL MARKETS?
THE WHOLE OF AMERICA?
Janice: WHO DID YOU LIKE
BETTER IN THE SHOW LAST NIGHT?
Nigel: OH, NO DOUBT ABOUT IT--
I PREFERRED WATCHING MERCEDES.
Janice: THANK YOU.
MERCEDES HAD THAT NATURAL RHYTHM
OF A WALKER.
I DIDN'T SEE THAT SO MUCH
WITH YOANNA.
Nigel: YOU'VE HIT THE NAIL
ON THE HEAD, I THINK.
Janice: THERE YOU GO.
Nigel: THIS IS VERY TOUGH
FOR ME.
Tyra: WAS THE WAIT DIFFICULT
WHILE THE JUDGES DELIBERATED?
WHAT WAS GOING THROUGH
YOUR MIND, YOANNA?
Yoanna: UM, UNCERTAINTY.
Tyra: MERCEDES?
Mercedes: INSECURITY.
Tyra: WELL, YOU MIGHT HAVE
BEEN UNCERTAIN,
AND YOU MIGHT
HAVE BEEN INSECURE,
BUT YOU GUYS HAVE COME
A LONG WAY.
YOU LOOK AT THAT SCREEN
RIGHT THERE.
WE ARE ABOUT
TO FIND OUT
WHO WILL BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
YOANNA,
YOU STARTED OFF AS THE QUIRKY,
KIND OF WEIRD GIRL,
AND YOU HAVE
TRANSFORMED
INTO THIS HIP, STYLISH,
GORGEOUS BEING.
A FACE LIKE YOURS
DOES NOT COME AROUND OFTEN.
MERCEDES, YOU STARTED OFF
AS THE CUTE GIRL IN THE MALL,
AND THE JUDGES
WERE LIKE,
"OH, SHE'S SO COMMERCIAL.
SHE'S SO COMMERCIAL,"
BUT, GIRL,
YOU EDGY RIGHT NOW.
YOU HAVE MADE
THAT TRANSFORMATION.
THAT LEAP.
EVEN THOUGH YOU GUYS HAVE COME
VERY FAR,
THERE'S
ONLY ONE SPOT.
Tyra: AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL IS...
Tyra: YOANNA.
YOANNA IS
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Yoanna: THANK YOU SO MUCH.
Tyra: CONGRATULATIONS.
Yoanna: THANK YOU.
Tyra: YOANNA LIVED
AND BREATHED FASHION, STYLE
AND MODELING
SINCE CHILDHOOD.
YOANNA'S DREAM
HAS COME TRUE.
AND THE FASHION INDUSTRY
HAD BETTER HOLD ON TIGHT
'CAUSE YOANNA'S
ABOUT TO ROCK YOUR WORLD.
♪♪♪
Mercedes: I WANTED IT
SO BAD.
AND I DREAMED
OF THIS MOMENT HAPPENING,
BUT IT AIN'T
GOING AWAY.
Yoanna: (screams)
IT'S NOT REAL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
♪ I NEVER WAS A CHEERLEADER ♪♪
NEVER MADE
THE SQUAD.
NEVER MADE HOMECOMING
OR PROM QUEEN, NOTHING.
I WAS ALWAYS JUST THERE,
AND I NEVER WON,
AND NOW I'M
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
♪♪♪
(giggling)
YOU SHUT UP.
♪♪♪